okay we got to talk about looper they're
gonna be spoilers if you haven't seen it
or if you care just click on the thing
right down there the little - that's the
pause don't watch spoilers for looper
alright uh I really liked louver and I
really liked the people in it I like
Rian Johnson who wrote and directed it I
think he's a really smart guy and I
liked the movie that he made with the
star one of the stars Joseph
gordon-levitt they made this movie brick
it was a high school film noir it's
fantastic
I like Joseph gordon-levitt every one I
know of every possible sexual
orientation likes Joseph gordon-levitt
in that way he is four quadrant appeal
if you know what I mean he's terrific in
it and Bruce Willis is terrific in it
you have to respect the movie that
understands that if you have Bruce
Willis above the mantelpiece in act 1
that by act 3 he should be killing lots
of guys with twin p90s that's a kind of
organic understanding of what Bruce
Willis is there for and I think that it
really handled time-travel right I'm
sort of OCD about my time-travel I think
that the details are what make a good
time travel story but lupard plays that
trick that the good doctor who does
which is basically says look
wibbly-wobbly timey-wimey right you
don't have to understand the details to
enjoy this as a movie and I think that's
a slick move because since there's no
such thing as time travel you kind of
get to say what you want about it
okay no no I'm stopping you I'm sorry
I've been to the future of this episode
of the observation deck by which I mean
we already shot it and I was there for
it you're totally missing that problems
with the time-travel in this movie and
you're about to blow it and this episode
is gonna be terrible and the commenters
are gonna savage you so I'm here to stop
you me you're here to stop all right
wibbly-wobbly timey-wimey you see my
point the thing is that it's not the big
arcs in time-travel that can blow a
story it's the little things the details
so I'm totally willing to grant and you
should be willing to grant that
lupard sort of hand waves and says look
you don't have to understand how this
works
so like alright maybe there's some kind
of like prospective propagation of
paradoxes so that
it's not that when a paradox happens
what something happens in the past it's
already happened in the future but in
fact like something happens in the past
looks forward exactly thirty years so it
looks a little bit like the UM the ten
thousand year family tree thing that
sherry Tepper wrote about so you know
okay maybe but let's look at the small
stuff take as an example
you can't kill somebody in the future
right that's the there's the cops are
too good so you got to send them back
why can't you just kill him in the
future and send the body back why can't
you just kill them in the future and
send the body right into the incinerator
why can they kill Bruce Willis's wife
but not Bruce Willis alright seriously
this is not helping my self-loathing
problems because I think you're an idiot
which is weird why can you not kill
somebody in the past and then have them
disappear in the future if none of the
changes will happen by which I mean so
there's no paradox you can kill somebody
in the past like you could kill Joseph
gordon-levitt and his future self would
still do all of the things that he had
done but they couldn't kill Paul Dano
they had to cut pieces of him off first
and presumably keep alive the carcass
for thirty years that doesn't quite
track why do you have to strap the money
to the bodies when he send the money
separately
why do loopers have to use the
blunderbuss gun and the other cool guys
like garret dillahunt who I love he's
awesome Donna has to use a pistol these
are problems these are yeah I'm gonna go
for it loopholes and that wouldn't bug
me so much except you know you've made a
lot of these I've watched a lot of these
science fiction has to respect viewers
or else people think it's Ashlock and
and these little things these are
loopholes that should have been closed
because they they diminish the movie now
I still really like it but it doesn't
you know it didn't go here the way I
wanted it to and I think I think it
could have I think it's a little bit of
missed opportunity that's it I still
think Rian Johnson should direct Justice
League you know first of all you're
overthinking oh no no you know as an
entertainment as genre you're supposed
to absorb a gestalt did I just go French
in German God how do you stand sitting
through these I I do think that um
that's actually okay to have some of
those things that make you think when
you walk out of movie theater because
it's one of the things that makes looper
not just
right you walk out and you really want
it to work and not in that way that like
when we walked out of prometheus and we
were you know enraged like I wasn't
raised by this I wanted to engage with
the movie yeah I think that's the
important part here I really do think
that the movie works overall even if you
kind of walk away going couldn't you
just maybe a little turn the dial
don't be Weasley about it I'd have to
kill myself and make you disappear um
plus the totally right he should direct
Justice League